one of the big questions of course in
the in the aftermath of the supreme
court overturning roe v wade is great
you'll force all these women to have
children that they don't want or don't
feel equipped or don't have the money to
have
who is going to help the women who's
going to pay for the kids because it's
not very pro-life
to force a birth
and then do nothing for the mother or
the child in that situation and in fact
i tweeted about this uh sort of
tongue-in-cheek by saying now that roe v
wade and i know that i've misspelled roe
the the voice to text misspelled that i
throw myself at your mercy now that roe
v wade has been overturned the right
wing will show their devotion to
children by expanding the child tax
credit funding child care in pre-k paid
maternity and paternity leave etc i
can't wait for them to do it and of
course it's tongue-in-cheek because they
don't plan to do that well trump suckup
republican governor of south dakota
christie gnome was interviewed over the
weekend by martha raddatz
and she was asked what are you going to
do for these women you said they will
never be alone
what exactly does that mean her answer
leaves a little bit to be desired but we
want to help support these mothers i
think we can do better in this country
making sure that we're walking alongside
them in these situations and making sure
that they do have the type of health
care and the support financially that
they need we'll look let's look at that
support the nonpartisan commonwealth
fund a social policy think tank
says the 14 states that have the most
restrictive abortion laws including
south dakota invest the least in
policies and programs for women and
children so right
what do you mean when you say these
mothers will never be alone yes
well i would say that the facts on the
ground are that south dakota is doing a
lot to coordinate with nonprofits with
churches and then also the state in a
new way by launching this website and
committing to in legislative session to
support these mothers is incredibly
powerful you know this is a conversation
that okay so so far she said we're going
to help support women
we're going to walk alongside women we
are doing a lot with churches
and we are going to um oh and
non-profits as well and they're going to
really talk about this in legislative
session wow well it sounds like it's
going to be fine doesn't it we have a
change now at the federal level the
states will be each evaluating how they
approach this situation right getting
health care to mothers helping them
during a time of crisis is incredibly
important and these states remember
martha are overwhelmed right now with
other situations that are going on with
what joe biden is doing to the energy
prices and guys how can you expect south
south dakota to help the women force to
birth a child
when there's an energy crisis created by
joe biden yeah i mean south dakota has
to deal with that they can't help the
women
um and then here's another uh oh and
this is also interesting
um
even though
christy gnome says a bunch of times that
women shouldn't be prosecuted for
getting an abortion
she leaves open the door
to prosecuting women who leave the state
to get an abortion and then come back
listen to this
and just one more question what if your
constituents travel to another state to
get an abortion right
you know that certainly isn't addressed
in our statute today and so it's not
addressed
in our statute today
okay that's not a statement of opinion
though that's just what it is right now
i think that's things that they'll be
debate about there will oh there will be
debate about what to do about that wow
but also we're having lots of debates in
south dakota how fundamentally our life
has changed the last couple of years
just with increased costs and inflation
and what this administration is doing to
every single family's budget so
understand she is not saying oh martha
no no no if someone goes to another
state where abortion is legal and then
comes back
obviously we're not going to do anything
about that that's not the way the law
works that's not the way states work no
no she actually deflects and then talks
about joe biden in energy prices
she's leaving the door open just saying
we will actually try to prosecute women
who leave go to a state where abortion's
legal have an abortion and then come
back
they're going to try
i'm not saying they will succeed
but they're going to try